[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I took a nap by the
way right before you got here yeah a
little bit yeah I tried to fall asleep
but I did for a minute and then all of a
sudden front door open dogs barking I
don't know Ryan here oh no my bad no
well I needed to wake up he said come at
four and I came at four thank God you
didn't come at three I know actually I
would have rather come at three coming
in four there's a lot of traffic coming
up this direction no I feel bad it makes
God makes me feel guilty uh thanks for
listening the last couple weeks have
been really great we had Eric McCormick
and Stephen Weber on the podcast last
week week before James Gunn which
exploded and uh it was good to see it's
good to see when the podcast got there I
gets out there I've been getting a lot
of calls and uh for those of you who
haven't listened to the podcast and are
here for Andrew McCarthy stay tuned but
just a few words we don't we don't talk
forever these are these are short intros
but um you know I'm very grateful if you
like the pop cast by the way the podcast
um subscribe write a review it truly
helps the podcast and uh you know tell
someone say hey I heard this podcast
it's uh you know it's decent and uh you
know I try to bring out a lot out of
each each guest whether you know them or
you don't know them and uh this episode
with Andrew McCarthy we talk about
walking with Sam's new book and uh I
found it fascinating uh you know father
and a son walking across Scotland or
whatever and really getting personal and
in depth uh just into their lives and
you know whatever and uh it got real
it's it's gonna get real when you're
doing something like that so and uh you
know I was always a fan of Andrew
McCarthy and
yeah I also found out he's not that much
older than I am I always felt like these
guys you know when I was younger were uh
oh my gosh you know he's Pretty in Pink
and
he's not that much older than me which
you know time's weird man what I'm
saying Andrew is you're not old
um hey if you want to follow us Ryan
tell them the handles at inside if you
pull out on Twitter and said if you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook I
haven't said that in a while I know
and uh Tom Welling and I will and
Kristen crook the threesome of
Smallville will be in Montreal
Montreal July 15th weekend we're doing a
small nights we're signing autographs
pictures all that's going to be a blast
my grandmother just had her 95th
birthday and I went down there and I
organized the whole thing because I'm a
control freak
and uh you know it was a nice time there
was some
you know some things that weren't as
smooth I won't get into those but uh you
know it made me sad that she doesn't she
she's 95 of course her memory is not
going to be great but I didn't realize
it would go that fast and in the last
three to six months
I showed her a video of the trip after
you know um after her big birthday night
and uh
brought her to tears but then the next
morning when I said did you love the
video she didn't know what I was talking
about and I showed her again like she
had seen it the first time so it's
pretty bad
and so I told my Uncle do me a favor on
her refrigerator
just put call Mikey with a picture of me
and my phone number your grandson
and uh he wouldn't put your favorite
grandson because his tickets would be
upset with that but he did put your
grants on so I got a call from her today
so I think maybe it works keep that you
know
it's on her fridge if she's going to the
fridge that's good you know what else my
my um cousin sent me a picture of the
inside of her uh refrigerator
and it had like ensure you know the old
people drink I think other people take
that too
but it had a glass of wine covered up
with plastic
like Saran Wrap whatever and it was like
she drinks the cheapest shittiest
freaking wine and she's preserving it
she's just like a little bit she doesn't
want to waste it oh God so anyway
um so what else uh the band we just had
a concert uh sunspin we're gonna be
playing those monthly so go to
stages.com or go to sunspin.com get a
ticket we have zooms other stuff you
could also get a zoom with me and Rob uh
my guitarist and chat with us uh the
inside of you online store has a lot of
cool stuff uh this guy's Santiago where
in the hell is
that's what I was asking you for but
then was the second I said it I realized
that the Santiago is not where the San
Diego is and it was wrong yeah
and I regret it now yeah you ruined it
you ruined the moment
damn uh anyway uh these little busts the
Smallville busts they're bad ass he made
boxes for them get them there's only
four available so if you want those
there's also Lex Luthor statues uh
funkos and tons of stuff I want to thank
the Funko store I went to the Funko
store in Hollywood I did an interview
which is coming out soon and I brought a
couple friends and they let us shop and
get as many funkos as we wanted
Funko that [__] man it was awesome I
love Funko thank you to everyone there
Tracy thanks for hooking it all up and
uh I got a lot of cool stuff if you
haven't been go to the Funko store in
Hollywood Boulevard it will blow your
mind it's like Disney World and another
was one it's dude you'll it'll blow your
mind I'll Take You Wanna Go sure it's
great
um so thanks there
um and a few
thank yous to uh
the non-profits that I work with
foodonfoot.org for homeless Echoes of
Hope for foster youth the Ronald
McDonald House uh the animal rescue
mission if you want to rescue animals
get a hold of the animal rescue mission
on Instagram or whatever ask for Shira
say I sent you
and uh All That Jazz and thanks for
listening to talk Ville we're going to
be coming back soon with new episodes
season three very exciting Ryan
it's going to be a good season so and
thanks thanks mostly to the patrons who
support these podcasts because I could
not do these podcasts without you
um thanks for the support and the love
and uh check out patreon.com inside of
you or slash talkville and become a
patreon member today all right without
further Ado let's uh let's get into this
let's get uh so much to talk about with
Andrew McCarthy it was it was a lot of
fun and uh you know we get into it so
let's get inside of Andrew McCarthy it's
my point of view
you're listening listening to inside of
you
you Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience it's a great setup thanks I
noticed you were looking at it now is
that sarcas sarcasm no because oh it's
great are you what are you into
what do you mean I mean you're obviously
into travel you're obviously into
writing and directing all these other
things and acting but like do you have
any like do you keep things you need
posters no I was actually more talking
about your technical setup not not your
not your Gap not my freak Show no not
your freak show that that I didn't even
really notice no I was looking more the
technical setup that was good yeah I had
somebody come and set this up and I'm
always scared that the uh the camera's
gonna just go and I'm like oh [__] what
camera like okay Lumix I gotta order
this so we gotta hook it up I shouldn't
worry about that should I rhyme okay
thank you
um well you got so much going on first
of all your your agent or your publicist
sent me that the book is now your new
book is in the New York Times bestseller
list and this just happened yeah
yesterday yeah so that's walking with
Sam yeah and that's always a relief what
do you mean it's always a relief so
you've had other books the Memoirs the
brat was also bestseller yeah yeah so
which is great no no it's it's showing
because it's like it is the only way
that
you know the broad way that people keep
score if you you know if you can claim
uh it's a New York Times yourself then
you can claim success oh it's real yeah
Dad it's like it's an independent movie
oh so it's not a real movie yeah no but
it's also when you've been out there
shamelessly promoting it like I have if
it doesn't do something you kind of go
oh you've been really selling there and
they weren't buying huh so anyway it's
it's a it's wonderful and exciting and a
relief my biggest fear is you know some
people said write a book and I'm like no
one cares about me I mean my listeners
may be like what I taught but like okay
so how many people buy my book because I
have I have some great
well I mean great stories starting from
childhood to craziness to
try you know getting to Hollywood and
getting mixed up with the wrong crowd
and all that stuff in between living
with Carrie Fisher it would be a chapter
and not sexually
um but I don't think my fear is like
you've been you've been there you were
like I mean for God's sake share the
headphones all right but like you know
you've done so much people know who you
are what they think they do anyway yeah
which is good you know that has its
pluses and minuses yeah I mean I get on
the T The Today Show or whatever or the
Good Morning America to talk about my
new book because I was in movies 30
years ago you know what I mean right so
I have that sort of platform if you will
so I you know I've become this sort of
cultural uh you know Touchstone for a
generation of people but normally like
when someone comes on the on the podcast
they want to promote something I'm like
it's not that I'm like oh [__] all right
you know I'm like all right we'll talk
about it but that's not really what the
podcast is about but this your book is
what the podcast is
because walking with Sam is sort of like
a journey with your son right yeah
across the country 500 Miles yeah
and like when I hear that you open up
about your life to your son it's just so
foreign to me and so so beautiful that
you know I didn't know anything about my
father in fact I remember calling him up
one time and he wasn't the kind of guy
I'm sure you're very close you're very
close with your son where you're like I
love you son I'm proud of you that kind
of thing
yeah
well you're hesitant
sure I hope I don't say it that yes I I
am yeah go on no but I just think that I
remember I was 20 something early 20s
and I I was just like he always I never
smoked and never drank and never did
drugs he was always very very critical
very hard on me
and I went to his dentist and I
shouldn't have gone to his dentist
because it was this guy out in Long
Island is Lauren said Lawrence Olivier
no why what was that about no well in
Marathon Man he's the dentist you know
anyway yes yes yes yes I remember I
remember the Dustin Hoffman is it safe
yes is it safe
you do a lot of Impressions no that was
it that's it that's it yeah but I went
out to his dentist and he was a good
dentist but his Dental place was in his
house in Long Island so it was cut fight
tooth decay with Dr J and I went in
there and he was this kind of what were
you thinking that should have been your
first clue I had no money and this guy
was gonna take care of me and uh I was
like what was my dad like oh your dad
[__] your dad was he was you know did he
ever do drugs did he do drugs I think he
invented Coke I think and all this stuff
came out and women and I'm like what
whoa whoa and I called my dad I go I
don't I don't [__] know you you've
lied to me all these years she's like
it's like you what do you want to hear
is this what do you want to know I'll
tell you what you wanted and I go do you
do drugs yeah I did a lot of drugs it
got to that point where like yeah did
you have sex with other girls and Mom
just what are you [__] kidding of
course yes I'm like okay and I just
started hammering with these questions
and he answered them but I didn't I
still to this day I don't know my real
thought I mean I know my biological got
it yeah you know what I'm talking about
my dad's just very um
uh it maybe it's just old school it's
old school where he doesn't want me to
get inside but I I get inside but I'd
like to know more about my father I'd
like to know the real story and the
things that he went through right and
because when I looked at what your
book's about it made me think you know
wow his son Sam right yeah obviously
unless you're walking with somebody else
and Sam
that he's really getting to know his dad
and really seeing the things that hurt
him and the mistakes he made and like it
seems like it was such an honest Journey
just tell me about that well you're
talking about your debt you know when I
left home at 17 and my relationship in
essence ended with my dad right then you
know my dad was a very volatile guy and
we were I was terrified of him so I left
home and we had no real relationship
through the rest of his life I mean he
died I guess just like six or seven
years ago and I mean I saw him probably
a dozen times in all those years and my
dad when I was young and successful my
dad uh when I was in the first in the
movies you know my fortunes were Rising
as my dad's fortunes were falling
emotionally and financially and so he my
dad used to come to me for money which I
found
that really twisted me up because I gave
it to him you know my when my dad first
you know they go if I don't get you know
50k I'm gonna jump off a roof I'm like
okay here's 50 cat you know what I mean
until finally that went on for a number
of years and then I finally you know he
said I'm gonna jump off a bridge if I
don't get whatever and I said well you
know what you're just like a heroin
junkie and I'm not giving any more
heroin to jump off the bridge and that
pretty much ended our relationship and
for decades really and I think he
regretted that later but um I just it
really
that was difficult because what what I
needed when I was a young kid and being
successful in that way that I was when I
was in these movies when I was young in
my early 20s I would have you know
welcomed some kind of backup and I
didn't I felt like I was being undercut
as opposed to being backed up you know
or supported so
inside of you is brought to you by
Harry's Harry's Razors why did I not
know about these guys when I'm shaving
my head on Smallville and getting nicked
in my head every time they'd shave me uh
I love Harry's Harry's sends me the
razors every month and these are just
better razors you know you go to the
grocery store and you pay a fortune
these are way cheaper they're way better
they have other products uh shaving
creams and lotions uh these guys are
awesome they have these starter sets
that are 13 value for just three dollars
at harrys.com inside you get a five
blade German engineered razor weighted
handle foaming shave gel travel cover
I mean scheduling delivery as little
refills as little as two dollars half of
what you pay for other blades
um it's pretty fantastic Harry's how can
how did I never hear about Harry's
because my back's hairy and I could use
Harry's to shave it
you could you could yeah Harry Potter
Harry's no it's it's a good product I've
used Harry's yeah I just think it's it's
phenomenal I mean these are Sleek
ergonomical weighted handles that look
great in your bathroom
give you precise control with each swipe
when I say weighted it's like the top it
almost feels like it's doing it for you
yeah you put it on your skin and just
I'm gonna make a sound
smooth sound against your face they
really are wonderful and for someone who
shaved their head for so many years as
Lex Luthor I would I would know this uh
you want the best shave uh no matter why
you shave Harry's has you covered for
the best shave of your life at a price
you'll love from their legendary high
quality razors to skin products like
exfoliating face wash and Hydrating
Lotion hairs gives you a premium shave
without the premium price tag get better
quality and a better price than other
razors when you get Harry's delivered
right to your door get your best shave
ever this summer with Harry's razors and
skin care products get a 13 starter set
for just three dollars at harrys.com
inside that's harrys.com
inside for a three dollar Starter Set
Harry's
inside of you is brought to you by neuro
hacker qualia cenolytic this stuff works
I'm saying it right now I'm saying it
clear I've said it before this is a
product that I didn't know they were a
sponsor and I was getting them thinking
I'm always on Amazon or whatever and I
probably ordered it and I started taking
it I noticed more clarity I noticed that
I was thinking straighter uh can you say
that thinking straighter yeah straight
in a straight line I was yeah but thank
you Ryan Yes
um and then I realized wait a minute
this is our sponsor oh this is great I
use this product it's not a hard sell
for me it's just uh it's easy to talk
about uh look our sponsor neuro hacker
packs seven of the most science-backed
cenolytic ingredients into one formula
called qualia cenolytic and you can take
it in just two days a month to help you
achieve fast noticeable benefits for a
much better aging process that's a you
know that is the the universe the world
we live in as people want to live longer
if they want to you know I my
grandfather passed away from Alzheimer's
my grandmother's you know very forgetful
if in the early days or early ages you
can start doing things for your mind
exercising the mind because most people
exercise their bodies and this and that
but if you could take something that you
know help helps your your mind that's in
my opinion this is the stuff that helps
me it helps me and I I urge you to try
it because you won't be sorry the
formula is non-GMO vegan gluten free and
the ingredients are meant to complement
one another factoring in the combined
effect of all ingredients together do
you say non-GMO I did say no you say
gluten-free I did vegan you're speaking
to the minds of a lot of people right
now Ryan look what I do this stuff is
also backed all right it's backed by a
hundred day money back guarantee this is
what I love they're so confident that if
if you don't like it for almost three
months well you return it try qualia
cinematic from neuro hackerate no
Financial Risk and decide for yourself
after three months I think you're going
to notice something uh if you're in your
late 20s or older adding neuro hackers
qualius analytic to your diet can play
it crucial in combating negative aging
symptoms go to neuro
hacker.com slash inside for up to 50 off
qualia cenolytic and as a listener of
inside of you use code inside at
checkout for an extra 15 off your first
purchase that's neurohacker.com inside
to try qualius analytic with code inside
and start aging on your terms these
statements have not been evaluated by
the Food and Drug Administration the
products and statements are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease
anyway I went when my dad was dying I
went to uh my wife said to her credits
because you need to go see your dad and
I was like oh
you're right and so I went to my dad as
you know as he was dying we didn't
really you know we didn't solve anything
but we just dropped it I dropped it
you know and I was able to be there with
him when he was dying and that was a
um a beautiful thing and I you know I
there was love there that remained it
hadn't I hadn't felt and you know all I
felt was fear and then anger and
resentmented him for undermine not
seeing me you know and so anyway so when
you talk about your dad like that uh I
didn't know really anything about the
one store I heard about my dad once when
his mom was uh
and put into an old you know a home
convalescent or yeah that kind of you
know for an old person and he went and
he kind of kidnapped her because he was
so upset by her being locked up so he
wouldn't he kidnapped her for a day
didn't know he didn't have any plan he
just needed to felt some need to act
like you know what I mean so he just
took her and he went to a motel and they
were staying there and his older brother
and my dad's at this point is I don't
know 60s or something 50s and his older
brother came and said let's have this
fight with my my older brother was there
to see this and his older brother they
stood in the argue parking lot arguing
these two brothers two grown men and my
dad's older brother slapped him upside
the head like you would a sibling young
sibling when your kids and I knew in
that intimate my brother told me that
story I was like oh I I instantly
forgave my dad so much because that's
where he came from and that's all he
knew you know like he was saying old
school different Generations whatever
you know but anyway so I didn't want
that with my son to bring it back to
kind of your question I didn't yeah I
wanted you know
my son that's the last thing I want
that's probably the biggest regret of my
life in a certain way it couldn't have
been other with my father but I really
regretted that lack there and I've
always felt that lack uh
there's like you know when my kids I
always say I want to be like a backstop
in Little League so if like I'm like you
go out in the world when you turn around
I'm gonna be here but you go out there
and you know whenever I turned around
when I was young I just thought somebody
poaching me or trying to stab me in the
back not there to sort of go yeah you
know what I mean and it's fine it's just
the way life was and it was fun and it
helped me in many ways to be you know
resilient whatever I didn't even really
notice it until years later when I've
begun you know enough therapy but
um and it was fine and I I don't I don't
mind it although I just don't want my
kids to have that I'm sure I'll screw
them up in other ways but you know I
wanted them to always know that like
their dad's right there behind them and
so anyway that's why I asked myself
that's yeah that's incredible and you
say that
um you weren't really affected you were
resilient you were obviously later on
you wanna be positive about it I mean
what I'm right no but I mean and also I
you know
it does those things you know you can
either choose to view these things as
something terrible that happened and
you're a victim of this person they're
easy to blame or it's like dude this is
what your life is and there are many
people have you know and like okay so
it's forced you to do this and that and
that and adjust in certain ways and it's
you know I'm all good with that right
you know I I think but what about
validation
did you ever feel like uh you needed
validation because your father
he found it my Dad loved me and he was
proud of me you know he used to stop
people on the street and I've I had
people stop me on the street when I was
much younger and go I Met Your Dad I'm
like yeah yeah I was crossing the street
and I read waiting in red light and he
said he just said hey do you know Andrew
McCarthy he's not my son and so like my
dad used to sort of weird you know if
they were the right demo he would stop
them you know and
which I found very sad in a certain way
I did that broke my heart before him I
was just that really made me sad I was
first humiliated by it and angered by it
when I was young and then it made me
very sad for him later but I mean I know
my dad was proud of me and you know all
that stuff but
in his way yeah you know it's weird
because I
sometimes people ask me this question
and then I'll go huh
and the question is do you think your
parents love you and they're so trying
to be in your life a little bit more
because you've had success because you
have because you have maybe a little
money because you have and so did you
ever have to deal with that where
there's like your father you say he
disappeared but then when you started
having the success he would see people
in the street he'd say that's my son he
was all this did you think okay but what
if I wasn't successful did that ever
haunt you like is he doing it because he
really well I think success
my public success young really harmed my
relationships and my family very much so
um I was not the star of the family
growing up you know what I mean my
brother I have three brothers two older
one younger and my oldest brother was
like smart and you know that and the
other one was The Jock and I was like
the sensitive kid or something but I was
not the star of the family you know and
when I became one in a public way at 21
22 years old that sort of blew up my
household
and or my you know my parents got
divorced around that time anyway so they
were going through their own thing but
it sort of blew up my relationships with
my brother my brothers uh because
they're still in their mid-20s trying to
figure out who they are and suddenly
their little brother is like some movie
star and you know what I mean that was I
think that was difficult for them to uh
navigate and so
I found the opposite with success in my
family and so it kind of made me because
of my temperament just sort of flee that
and go this isn't a safe place I'm I'm
you know what I'm a Loner a bit anyway
so I I kind of the combination of of
that and with feeling slightly poached
by them made me uh just flee you know
what I've had a lot I had a lot of
people early on asked me for money and
things when I was young and family
members do tonight and you know
invariably you give it to them at the
beginning Until you realize that people
whoever you give money to hate you for
it
because you're basically saying I'll do
for you what I see you can't do for
yourself and people hate you for that
and so everyone who I tried to help
financially resented me for it so I
stopped you know doing that I I still
enable I still do it I'm much better at
it now but it angers me that I do it my
actual my business so why do you do it
um because I don't want to feel guilty
when they die
uh-huh
that doesn't add up
[Laughter]
you know that that math that math it's
two and two is like five I I want to say
that hey I really did everything I could
and I was really a good brother or a
good son or a good whatever but it gets
to a point where it's like can't you cut
it off and still say you did that
because you did that for so long it's
like when does it end and you you came
to a point where you cut it off with
your dad
um
I haven't had my father doesn't need
money but like someone in my family they
do and they but they don't they have
always sort of you know been the victim
they've always sort of like you know I
need this I can't do this they're
married they have it it doesn't make
sense but I keep helping out because I
do love them and I want them to be happy
I don't want them to be destitute and
maybe there's an ego thing maybe there's
maybe there's sort of like oh if I let
that happen then all of a sudden oh they
can't then all of a sudden the town
where I grew up and all they're like oh
you you're
your family there you have money why
aren't you helping them maybe there's
that sort of like I care about what
other people think well of course
you know I give you money so I'm you
know I'm empowered I have power over you
now I don't want it I really don't I
don't want to have that power I just
want them to be happy and do whatever
they can to make ends meet and do the
things that I think are simple simple
steps into doing that because you know I
have friends that you know I know that
if I didn't have a job I would go get a
job if I didn't have money I would go
figure out how to make money these are
certain things that were ingrained in me
that I always knew and and it's easy to
save now when you're doing well but I
know that and a lot of people are like
that they're like hey I'll go I'll work
at McDonald's I'll work it wherever I'll
but maybe there's pride in whatever and
they don't want to do that for sure when
my dad was wanting money I always he
said I'd be proud of your dad if you're
a bad person in the checkout you know at
the supermarket but you know easy for me
to say yeah
that's true and it was that would have
been the truth but it wasn't he wasn't
being able to do that and I get that
yeah I get that I wouldn't want to be
bagging in the supermarket either hey
you're that guy from mannequin what are
you doing putting my groceries
um lastly about that because I really
want to talk there's so much to talk
about but uh you know I mean this is
sort of the center this is the the kind
of what I want to I mean the book is I
can't wait to read this book because I
feel like I need it I need to read this
book as you can tell when I'm telling
you these stories what didn't you tell
your son like what things were you like
I'm not going there with you well that's
an interesting thing because it was one
day that's one of the things I still
Wrangle with with my kids because I
don't need to be the buddy or their pal
I want to be their father and you know
but I want to have an adult relationship
with them and since I didn't have one
with my father I'd have no real template
for that which is why one of the reasons
we walked across Spain together I
thought because it was I did it 25 years
early and it was a profound thing for me
so I wanted to sort of
thought it might be helpful uh in
rewriting my son and I's dynamic
but um I've totally then just forgot
your question no it was just like the
things that you uh didn't say to your
son oh yeah so one day one day Sam said
we're about halfway through the walk and
Sam just turned to me and goes how are
you dad
and he was asking me
you know and I don't recall him ever
asking me that before you know he was
asking wanting to know and I
was at that time at that moment in those
previous shipments I've been you know
fretting about money been worrying about
work been you know thinking stuff about
my wife thinking you know in a worrisome
fretful mode and I
said to him I'm good Sammy I'm good and
it was a real missed opportunity to sort
of share Who I Am with my kid
particularly since I'm saying that's
what I wanted to do is for him to see me
more you know but you know I remember
when I was young I had this this never
left me my mother at times would she'd
have problems with my dad and she would
be very upset and I would come in and
she would say oh the child should never
see their mother cry and I'm like no Mom
tell me you know because I wanted to be
close to my mom naturally and she was
suffering so I would go into her and she
would tell me stuff that you know
it was emotionally what was happening to
her at the time but I interpreted with
my young ears as sort of settled fact of
that this is what she felt when in that
was just a transitory mood but I took
that and took that deep as though this
is what she believes and there's a big
difference you know and so and as a
young person I wasn't able to separate
those two particularly when it's your
mom doing that so I've often I've said
oh I don't want to do that with my kids
and yet how am I going to you know if I
want him to share with me himself with
me I have to do do that too I have to
model that and or meet him there or lead
him there so I I still find that a
challenging thing at times to do yeah
did you uh is that in the book where you
didn't say it you talk about yeah that
is in the book yeah I want to talk about
what was going on you know because it
was such an odd moment too because it
caught me so off guard and
I was so in a space of and kids know
everything you know they see right
through everything you know I was such
in a space of worry in that moment where
I wasn't often on the trip but in that
for whatever reason that morning I was
in in that space you know where we can
get and but to not share that with me
even wonder even to just say you know
it'll pass it's no big deal but I'm just
really worried about money I just you
know because money's you know blah blah
and talk to him about it like you know
it was a missed opportunity on my part
um is that something you would talk
about with anybody or not anybody but
with with yeah with anything
um well it is interesting thing about
how you know people often and it's in
writing too you people often I read that
Edward R Murrow the newscaster told a
stranger on the plane next to him and he
had cancer and he'd never told any of
his family at that point you know what I
mean there's something about telling
strangers things that's interesting it's
like when you write I'll often write
things that
my 16 year old daughter who asked me
something about my past and Sam said to
her if you want to know Dad you should
read his books
because
I'll write things and it's very true if
that goes to what we were just talking
about and also you know I'll be much
more forthcoming on a page than I will
be generally in life with people even
people I love and I always think and I'm
not the only one lots of people talk
about how that's the case and I think
that's really interesting how we do that
and why we do that and that's why they
say right what you know right yeah I
guess so and just write the truth right
because you write the truth right no I
remember writing the first book I didn't
I was right you know and it was a travel
Memoir but really it's about intimacy
and I remember writing a paragraph going
oh my God this could never be in the
book and I'm typing away and this could
never never there's no way I'm
embarrassed this is like way too
revealing yeah and then I finished and I
finish and I read it and I go well
that's there's no chapter without that
paragraph that's the whole thing and you
know because all you're trying to do is
you know they're just feelings
everybody's got them and you start with
writing you're just trying to create a
connection with the reader so that
they're nodding their head whether they
sit alone in their bed at night they
with you and they're nodding their head
and kind that's how I feel that's how I
feel and then you've then you've got
something yeah have you ever
like are you one of those I like I had
never heard my dad cry until he lost his
daughter my half-sister who passed away
a few years ago and talk about shell
shocked talk about
um and it was sort of expected
throughout the year she had the Trisomy
chromosomal thing going on for years and
she was she was always in the hospital I
mean she lived in the hospital
children's hospital and
you know he was dealing with this a lot
of time and then when she passed
I called him
and I I couldn't even understand him it
was like a different human being I've
never heard that kind of cry he was so
hurt and I just didn't know what even to
do I was emotional I was
I just said I love you I'm here for you
and it was
it was heartbreaking it was
heartbreaking it's not something I think
you want to see your father there's some
people like oh my Daddy's always crying
oh he's everything he watches this he
cries I think that's one of the greatest
things we can do for our kids is show
them our Frailty
you know what I mean we don't want to do
that as dads of course we're strong with
this or that when we got it sorted out
and you know but I think you know
there's a moment on the walk when we're
walking and I tripped and I fell and I
almost crashed into this thing that
would have really been a problem and
I hit hard and I normally jump bounce
right back up if I fall because I'm so
embarrassed that I just oh no I'm fine
fine you know but I didn't bounce back
up and I just felt and it's a much
lighter thing than what you're talking
about obviously but the metaphor of it's
the same is I I hit the ground and I
stayed there and my son was shocked at
this because I never I'm pretty agile on
that you know and so
and he helped me and I realized just let
him help you let him help you it's
important for him to see that part of me
you know what I mean and that's one of
the things I have to teach is that like
you know like my mom now is is not you
know she's came to mention She's
suffering and like
you gotta go help them and that's
anyway and so that's part of life that's
part of the cycle of what happens and so
you know
so yeah for you to say that's important
thing for your dad for you to get to
experience that with your dad you know
what I mean that it's not just the other
way it's you know it's not it's a
two-way street which you know it takes
being in wanting that too yeah
you know it's weird it's like um with me
he knows I have a podcast
but he doesn't know what I talk about
how I really open up and I'm probably he
probably would be you know he'd probably
be pissed off sometimes if I'm you know
talking about it but like I don't talk
to about him like I just talk about my
you know my feelings would have you know
life and
um
he doesn't know that I mean I think he
know he knows I went to therapy and but
it's almost like he doesn't want to talk
about that stuff he doesn't go to
therapy never would I remember when he
lost or I said you need to go to therapy
he's like why you think anybody knows
what I'm going through I go yes I do I
think people lose their whole families
on planes I think their people lose
their daughters and their sons and their
dog everything it's people there this
happens to a lot of people unfortunately
and if you talk to people and sit in a
circle with some people he's no no no
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that he
doesn't want to do that he doesn't want
to tap into his emotions he doesn't want
to and he never will that's just what it
is but so I never feel like I can talk
about any of that stuff because it's
just it's there's no reason to it'd just
be like oh okay yeah you know sorry to
hear that
uh anyway how'd the Mets doing
you know you know that's you know I used
to dismiss all that kind of sport jargon
but there's a certain intimacy that
comes with that and if that's the way
people can funnel it and so be it you
know yeah and it's also generational I
think to some degree sure but it's also
not there are guys that are like that
you know I mean and
you know
you never think
growing up did you have a confidence to
you were you popular that all of a
sudden you'd be this icon who was doing
these major Motion Pictures part of the
brat pack which to me is one of it's
probably the coolest thing that could
ever happen to someone I'm sorry there's
only six people that could say they're
part of the prep pack I think right
sure I'm just saying did you ever
imagine like I'm gonna be famous one day
oh you know I was no I was not a wildly
confident kid at all in any kind of way
no I I just when all that happened it
was head spinning and you know but you
you forget now the broad pack is this
wonderfully iconic term with spoken with
affection and reverence for this moment
in pop culture and for a certain
generation you know I and other members
of brought back are the Avatar of their
youth you know and so it's looked at
with these rose-colored memories because
it's that's the moment in life when
people are just cusping life when
they're 20 21 when they're you know the
life life is a blank slate to be written
upon and it's get out of the way World
here I come and it's just a thrilling
exciting moment and I represent that in
other other actors do too represent that
to a certain demographic of a certain
generation but that was not the case at
the brat pack when it came out
the term was coined in 1985 in a New
York Magazine article by uh a guy who
was writing an article on Emilio Estevez
and took turned off to him didn't like
him and was jealous of him I'd say
because he was also a young journalist
and so he wrote the scathing article
about all these young actors and called
them the brat pack it wasn't Canby was
it no it wasn't a guy named David Blum
um
Vincent came in Houston he was another
story but um
anyway so it was a really negative
pejorative thing and we [__] hated it
and it we thought who wants hey who
wants
because he wants to be in a pack I
didn't hugely it adversely affected our
careers because we were happy yeah we
were now perceived as this you know all
you ever want in life is to be seen
right see me see who I am that's what
your whole thing is about this is who I
am see me and in the instant the brat
pack label came out it was like
or something we were 180 you know that
it turned hard and we remembered the
brat pack and I was unseen for like
that's
and that it's taken you know me decades
and centuries to have that go 180
degrees to embrace it as this beautiful
thing which it is now but we forget that
it wasn't at the beginning and
um you know we had I was like you know
Martin Scorsese is not going to call up
anybody in the brat pack you know and he
never did so I mean you know but so it's
been a long journey and I know for for
me and for I know the other people as
well to sort of pivot through that to
now where you know where it's landed for
me which is that that it's this sort of
this beautiful thing to represent that
for that generation of people but that
wasn't the case and it was largely just
that notion of I felt unseen suddenly
here I was just starting life just
starting my career okay here I come and
then bam no you're labeled you're
pigeonholed in this thing and this is
this is what you are from one article
which is amazing you know in our culture
now with every all the different things
yeah there was one article one week in
New York within days the countries
because it was such a good phrase you
know Brat Pack boom yeah I mean you
don't forget it's there it's indelible
and you know
and it was also a cultural shift to
happening when young youth took over
rebellious well no but just you took I
mean the movies were not about kids up
to that point really and then they
discovered in the early 80s my God these
kids go to the movies five six seven
times grown-ups go once let's make
movies for kids and we were right there
at the right place at the right time you
know and so then John Hughes comes along
and says oh wait young kids emotions
should be taken seriously
um and you know because nobody's when
you're 17 18 you fall in love for the
first time you were the first person to
ever be in love right and so and that
first heartbreak is the first heartbreak
ever and is the magnitude of it and John
who's knew that and honored that and so
kids saw that one that's me
you know and that's why generation the
Next Generation those those women have
shown their daughters and their
daughters looking at that moving Pretty
in Pink and going the hairdos are funny
but that's me you know yeah and so
that's why they live on in that way and
to sort of you know for me to come to
represent that's a beautiful thing but I
always kind of not always I never looked
at it like that like no but now I'll
hear you again of course the Jew that's
so interesting it's like yeah you you
didn't realize the impact it had on you
guys it sounds so cool now and to
everybody on the outside looking in I
want to be the brat pack but I could I
could see how it was just sort of like
[__] I'm more than that yeah or I'm
other than that yeah I am more than you
know that's
yeah and for someone like me I was very
much a you know a solitary personal
loner a bit so to be slumped in with all
these guys who I liked fine but I didn't
know them I don't think I ever went out
socially with any of them ever you know
really so you never you were on these
movies on these hugees I lived in New
York and so I would just whatever it's
but did you get close with anybody
yeah I mean I liked him and then I mean
no but you never know any of them no
because I saw the article yesterday that
came out or the other day
um about Emilio Estevez who hadn't seen
him in 30 years yeah I hadn't seen any
of them I made a documentary recently
about this because I wrote a book a few
years ago about my time then my life
then and because I was like it was a
rock I never looked under and so I
decided to look under it and I'm like
that's how I came to the position that
I've sort of was just talking about how
I've come to realize what a beautiful
thing it is and what I'm blessed in that
way really truly and then but I didn't
feel that way and so I thought that okay
I had a size that was a seismic event in
my life the brat pack what was it like
for everyone else because I know it was
for them too because we were in the same
boat we're members of a club we didn't
ask to join and we have we can just look
at each other and kind of go
hey dude and we just know and so I went
back and talked to everybody who Amelia
hadn't seen 30 years Rob I haven't seen
in 30 years to me you know any Ally she
hasn't seen any of them and to just get
their take on it and it was really
interesting yeah I I just do you think
um if you look back do you think that
they were probably like ah he's doing
his own thing he's too good for us while
we're all partying and yeah
they were into their own thing you know
what I mean everyone's so self-centered
no one's thinking about anybody else you
know but I also was you know I was so
afraid really then that always then that
manifested as a sort of aloofness when I
was just afraid
you know so yeah and so yes and I was
always baffled by people saying oh
you're so you're arrogant you're aloof
and I'm like really I'm just [__]
scared here you know something yeah so I
I always felt sort of unseen in that
regard you know was there any anybody
that you could recall
on set that you worked with or you're
like female that you were like gosh you
know I should have stayed in touch with
her I should have asked her out or I
should have you know I should have like
I was really attracted to this person
and I just dropped the ball there I I
didn't take a chance
well I was better at it with women than
I was with just friendship because you
know women then you could you know
you're thinking you're in your 20s
you're thinking sex so that gives a
little more motivation than friendship
you know so Emilio
so uh so with that regard you know I
sort of went for things a little more
than I might have if it was just
friendship involved did you always love
acting or was it something that
you're good at you're getting roles you
were doing it because I know you do
Broadway right I did yeah you did
Broadway so you obviously love theater I
did yeah no I wanted to that's what I
thought I would be was a theater act I'd
never occurred to me I'd be in the
movies you know I mean when I was 15
years old I was cut from the high school
basketball team and I my mother said try
out for the school play and I'm like I
don't want to be in the play I want to
be the point guard you know so but I did
and I was cast as The Artful Dodger and
Oliver and when I walked out on stage at
you know my life changed it was like
Tennessee Williams The playwright has a
lineup talking about love he says it's
as if a room that had always been half
and shot I was suddenly in the light and
that's how I felt the minute I walked
downstairs went oh my god there I am
there wow and I knew it was important
because I told no one you know I thought
I knew it was like a little flame
flicker that had lit and if anybody
could walk by and blown it out you know
what I mean like when I told him
eventually told my father I wanted to be
an actor and go to college for acting he
said no son of mine's gonna be a [__]
thespian you know and you know so well
yeah I mean you know so maybe I was
right not to bring it up earlier but by
that point I knew what I was doing and I
didn't care what anybody said and I was
going to go do it I had no idea how I
had the wonderful gift of Youth which is
you don't know things are impossible so
that's so true yeah and so then you know
it happened for me very quickly although
it doesn't feel quick at the time when
you're young into the stuff but you know
what is that I was just talking about
this about ambition and it's like I
remember being in college and like
getting casts in the lead casting the
lead roles and you know the the all the
heads of the department were like you're
ready you need to go to York and this
this guy this actor Leo burmester who
came into town and we all gave
monologues and he took me aside and said
you got it you have what it takes you
need to do this it's in your heart block
and all the confidence then was just
like I I let's go and I didn't I
remember people like you know the
percentage like there's no percentage of
actors I here's the thing I didn't ever
think for a second that I wasn't going
to beat the odds I know that what I'm
doing is gonna I'm gonna make it I swear
to God I thought that and what happens
is life happens and you start to do
things and if you don't have this solid
foundation like I said and everything's
sort of need to be validated you're
great eventually there comes a time
where you're like
um
I I felt like fear got in the way and
ambition kind of took the side took a
step aside I felt like I don't I never
have that ambition like I had that
energy that just like I'm going for it I
I felt like that has been sort of lost
if not lost it's you know there's
remnants but it's sort of uh it's not
like it was do you feel like that
happened with you at all sure and once
you experience failure then you can't
forget that and if failure goes you go
whoa okay so then there's doubt and then
in that doubt Creeps in fears and all
those anxieties and all those kind of
things for sure for sure yeah I mean
did you has that happened like were you
confident on sets when you were acting
were you were you enjoying it were you
loving being on set and acting in fact I
love being on sets actually I do love
being honest I you know
I I direct a lot of TV now and I always
say that Orange is the New Black yeah
and I said you know directing is
stressful but acting creates anxiety
you know what I mean yeah and I find
asking well you know
so but I love being on a set I you know
I thought it was most at home on a set
in many ways and I've been on sets for
my oh since I was 18 years old and so I
understand that world like I'm never
bored on a set people talk about boring
now I'm never bored wow I found it just
very interesting yes it's weird
directing someone like some of you
probably are friends with back in the
day like James Spader in Blacklist
uh no I mean you know James is such a
wonderful and peculiar guy anyway I mean
he's that's all he's his own beast but
um and I just know him so long I have a
shorthand with him so it's nice but no
I've ever acted neuroses there is so
it's easy for me to talk to actors yeah
because I just understand what they're
doing so yeah do you ever get uh
have you ever worked with someone where
you're like I cannot stand working with
this person I hate it I have to get out
of here I don't want to do it I'm not
comfortable I don't I'm not my craft
isn't coming through because I'm
thinking too much now or whatever I'm
not sure I've had on from acting and
directly sure there are people just like
oh my you know I'm directing somebody
I'm like this guy's terrible how much
money is he making every week you know
what I mean you have to make him look
good yeah and that's your job so you
know so yeah of course I mean TV
directing that's a whole other topic but
it's also really not a very satisfying
job why is that well you're servicing
um someone with TV is a writer's medium
right you know so you're servicing
someone else's vision and so if you're
going to work that hard ultimate it's
great like I always call it TV directing
like going to director Jim like this
week you're doing chess next week you're
doing arms because like you're shooting
in different styles different kind of
and so that's all very interesting but
ultimately unless you're doing your own
thing yeah it's not very satisfying and
they'll just get some you know get
someone else to do it once the TV show
is up and running it's just you know
making the sausage and
shows can happen without a director very
easily you have a good DP and you have
the directions and the actors don't
listen to you anyway so they're you know
it directs itself and there are many
examples I mean of people that have no
idea how to direct it or directing TV
shows and you notice you know you'll
watch a show and you'll kind of go yeah
that one was really good it has flow to
it you know and that's the direct you
know because TV directing really what
you have is transitions you know because
every TV show is going to end up in a
close-up you know but you know so
there's certain things you have and if
you can talk to an actor that's helpful
but ultimately I don't find it utterly
satisfying rewarding work right I
remember Greg Beeman
worked on on Smallville with me and he
used to he would shoot this Warner and I
go hey are you going to coverage now he
goes
no it's a Warner I'm like okay uh he's
why are you doing don't they get mad
like yeah they want close-ups and this
and that and I'm like but now I'm not
giving that a choice
this is this is what I want to do and it
tells the story and now they don't have
an option they're not going to cut into
the close-up because they can't
yeah no it's great yeah I agree what's
the uh if you have to look back at the
one one movie that you're most proud of
oh I know that's hard I I don't know
proud I don't know what proud means less
than zero that was a terrible experience
I did not enjoy that at all
um well I was in a bad place in my life
everyone was a script was a mess that I
didn't think that was a successful movie
um and then we had to reshoot so much of
it because it was right in the middle of
Nancy Reagan just say no era suddenly
and you know scenes with flushing
cocaine down the toilet because the
studio Executives realized oh this movie
is being made about our kids no we can't
have the you know and there's not a word
of the book in the movie and stuff so
you know that movie particularly didn't
you know that Bobby Johnny was great but
he was also you know a little too close
to home for him in that moment in time
so well he wasn't that easy because he
was going through it well he was lovely
but he was just going through whatever
he's going through he's always been a
very sweet guy yeah
um
so but no that movie didn't fight I I
say I have great affection for Weekend
At Bernies I think somehow Jonathan
Silverman yeah he's great Johnny's a
great guy he's great and you guys look
to be so much fun in the movie I
remember when it came out it was just so
hilarious and so original yeah no I
think it's great I think when's the last
time you've seen it and have you watched
it with any of the uh well I can
shamelessly tell you that I was in a
hotel about a month ago and I flipped on
the TV and I went into the bathroom as I
told you and I started hearing this
voice I'm like what is that and I went
back in it was me and weekend and
Bernie's and I watched like the last it
was the boat scene of chasing Dan so I
watched like the last 20 minutes of the
movie and in a while oh dude I'm not
even smiling I was sitting there
reciting the lines back to the TV alone
in my hotel room and I can't remember
ever watching a movement of mine like
that uh ever and it was so and I thought
it was absolutely hysterical I thought
it was great I think every I guarantee
I'd put everything I have on it that
every actor has set back by themselves
and watched something of themselves and
just had a smile or a moment oh yeah but
you know for decades I could never watch
any of my movies ever but I was so I it
was either incredibly narcissistic or
healthy when I was watching one laughing
at myself thinking how funny I was
I love that is there is there a song
from any of those do you hate hearing
those songs when they come up no they're
great I mean I hear that like OMD with
now OMD yeah yeah yeah um and that from
Pretty in Pink that song right and then
the one I hear seem to hear in the
supermarket or wherever all the time is
the mannequin where nothing's gonna stop
us now they used it on the skeleton
twins with uh Kristen wig and everything
you don't want to hear that song no I
mean I just thought it was such a Cheesy
song but people love it
and one song I heard recently I hadn't
heard in years was to say now almost
fire you know man in motion song which
is just such a a cringe you know as my
son would say yeah yeah yeah and it's
that's just so of a moment you know some
of those songs have really endured and
like become part of the popular culture
yeah you know but that one I think is
just such like of that moment that it
just brings you right back yeah and
there was the other one oh the uh
Psychedelic Furs yeah yeah I love that I
still go see them isn't she yeah no I
thought that was terrific yeah yeah they
have a lot of great songs actually in
fact they're going to be in Florida and
I just told my Uncle he has got to go
see them they're really fun and concert
they've got like six or seven songs
people they just think it's like Pretty
in Pink and stuff but they have more
than that uh you've been silver since
2002 July 3rd 2002 yeah so 20 years good
30 years do you ever miss it
have you ever thought about I'm gonna
have a drink
I can do this I can have one drink well
I certainly never think that I mean I
think once you're you know
pickle you can't ever become a cucumber
again and I see my obsessive and
compulsive addictive qualities in other
aspects of My Life
um but no you know I mean do I miss it
no I mean I so much because of because
of it yes because I stopped drinking and
doing drugs my life isn't feeling better
but it actually the ID itself having
been sort of
Afflicted if you want to use that word
or blessed with alcoholism has
it is the foundation from which
everything's brings forward so I'm so
grateful I'm grateful yes to have
stopped doing and been in recovery but
I'm grateful for it itself because it is
you know what's that old Greek line the
crack vase lasts longest in a certainly
everything comes from that nugget of you
know and it was a terrible several years
and it you know I let it ruin my career
and you know all sorts of things and but
and I heard people that I loved but it
I look back on it and I carry it every
day it's like that what a blessing it is
to not just recover yes of course but
that it itself that I am an uncle is it
was a huge blessing is it was there one
they always say when you hit rock bottom
I had a situation where I was like this
is this is the moment where you stop was
was there that or was there just kind of
a progression and you're like I I gotta
just this has got to stop
well I luckily didn't have I wasn't able
to function so I couldn't pretend that
it wasn't utterly consuming
my entire life so but I did have a
moment yeah I had a moment when I was in
a hotel I came out to L.A to do uh I
don't even know what afford to do but I
was at the Peninsula Hotel because I was
in the grandiose phase of blowing money
you know so I'd spend lots of money so
people wouldn't think there was
something wrong you know so and I
remember being up all night having
emptied my mini bar and I just hear I
Heard a Voice say um Andrew you do
whatever you want I'm tired and it
freaked me out I like literally was
looking under the couch and under like
who just said that
and you know I and and that and that
just cut through to me and I made a call
that then and I went and got help
so it was just sort of the one a moment
you know one of the few things I've had
in my life gifts I've been able to
recognize moments when they happened to
me when I first started acting in 15
when that moment we talked about and and
that was another one where I just sort
of recognized that and I said now you
know the call for help can come in a
whisper
wow that's incredible that you you heard
that or subconsciously you heard that or
whatever it was
it it I did hear that night you know and
I I consider myself very blessed in that
I you know it was lifted for me
it was just lifted for me and I I
consider you know some kind of Grace
happened to me and I'm not a religious
person in any way but I I do have feel
some kind of because I have proof of it
in my life there's no reason why I
should at all there's no reason why I
shouldn't still be drink or be dead by
now certainly if I drank the way I did
um you know there's no and so I just
think Grace happened in my life whatever
that means I don't even know what that
means and it's my obligation to sort of
Honor that yeah you're so open and
honest man this is I mean like I just
it's awesome it's freaking awesome thank
you for doing that this is called [__]
talking with Andrew McCarthy this is
fast Rapid Fire It's the end it's my top
tier patrons they're awesome thanks for
supporting the show at patreon.com
inside of you in there and you can just
rapid fire if you feel like answering it
like a little longer feel free you don't
have to be like uh yes
[Laughter]
what's your favorite scene to film on
the set of St Elmo's Fire
Bongos Bongos Bongos Bongos which I
thought actually when it was finished I
thought well I just ruined my career
thought well it's what I said to the DP
and I said boy that just that was a
career Ender and he said I think that
was a career maker son and uh yeah he
was right Kathy Joe what's one of your
favorite memories of working with John
Hughes
he used to show up uh because he didn't
direct it everyone thinks he directed he
used to show up around lunch time and
Sashay him with a little Boombox and
he'd play us little Snippets of music
and say what'd you think of that what do
you think at night he was creating the
soundtrack and he was listening to what
we were saying because that's what he
was did he on not only on screen in real
life he honored like he respected kids
uh Super Sam what Drew you to the role
of the res on the resident watching your
character struggle to balance with his
addiction while also needing the drugs
to perform his job was incredible I just
it was fun to act again they asked me
and I said oh I haven't acted in ages
let's do that it would be fun scary no
not at all it felt like you know they
said the joke about two fish swimming in
the in the ocean and one pass is the
other one says ain't the water Fawn
today and the other says what water I
mean if that's what felt like for me it
just felt like breathing to me going
back to it I really enjoyed it Jessica B
of all the TV shows you've directed
which one was your favorite and why
I love doing Orange is New Black at the
beginning because it was very exciting
time you know it was like we they were
inventing uh you know Netflix was they
were the company that mailed you DVDs
and you know what I mean they're making
the show and like when they said it was
going to be streaming I went okay cool
what channel is that on you know I know
I couldn't couldn't grasp that and then
when they told me it was going to be
they were going to put them all on in
one night I remember sitting in the
producer's office when I heard that and
I said well that's the stupidest idea I
ever heard and you know I was right
again and it just changed the way you
know we tell stories now so that early
on was very exciting uh Nathan Jay we
kind of answered this is James Spader an
intimidating person to work with no
James is um delish if you don't know
what you're doing he'll eat your life
but uh that's true so many talented
people you know they don't suffer fools
while I was on the set uh we were
laughing and one guy came up and said
well what uh what were you guys like
back in the day and James just looked at
him and said we're exactly the same only
now we're more so I'm like yeah I don't
know what the [__] that means but yeah
that's right
that's amazing Stone Age last question
did you get to keep any props from
Weekend at Bernie's uh one of your
all-time favorites or have you ever kept
any problems I did when I was young I
used to keep props a few one thing from
each show but I don't remember anything
I have from Bernie oh man this has been
awesome uh walking with Sam is out
it will be out it is out yeah it is out
yeah May 9th it came out yeah so this is
the best time New York Times bestseller
list yeah you know I care about it
because I talked about it because it's
so I want to learn things and how you
deal with family members and I just
think it's a beautiful journey and I
can't wait to read this just what I've
read about it and the interviews and
things like that what you've told me I
just it's it's a it's a must read you
got to do it and also you have the uh
the brat pack documentary that's yeah
that'll be a late fall probably late
fall you directed that yeah
um okay that's late fall so I'm
definitely you know that's going to be a
success you know everybody and their
mother wants to watch that well if it's
a generation it's I think it has certain
you know immediate appeal then we'll see
what else do you want to do what else
did you want to direct more do you want
to write more is there are there more
books because I'm writing I'm supposed
to be writing a pilot for uh for Sony
but you know once the strike's over
we'll get to that but uh so you know I
yeah I'm just I just like to you know
make stuff so I just keep making stuff
what about Alaska this is it what about
today in today's world when you look
back in the movies and the time and the
movies that were being made
the Blockbusters even the Star Wars and
all these things when you look at the
geography now
of the movies that are being made do you
like what's happening do you think it's
too much are there too many streaming
platforms or do you get lost and like
what the hell is going on do you is
there uh
there's just so many options it's like
this menu that it just never I think
it's all kind of fantastic you know I
mean I I think there's so many different
rabbit holes for people to fall down you
know when I was the thing about the
broad pack to go back after it was only
it was a very unified youth culture
there was one thing and so everyone knew
the brat pack that's why every one of
that is now there are a million little
things so there isn't that kind of
unified thing but I think it's fantastic
now all the different stuff that's going
on in different Avenues and you know the
first thing I ever heard when I came
into Show Business was oh it's so hard
now it's so hard you should have been
here a few years ago when we got tours
oh now it's so and all I've ever heard
is how hard it is anybody that says that
to Magic okay thanks Sharon I'm not at
all interested in hearing anything you
have to say you know what I mean don't
tell me how hard it is it's just like I
know no but it's always been harder to
always be hard yeah go go do your thing
and like shut up
you know what I mean yeah that's that's
the perfect way to end do your thing and
shut up uh thanks sir for being on here
this is awesome man thank you thank you
that was great
uh what can you say can't say much other
than a great guest yeah great guest uh I
was a little nervous because he's you
know he's an icon it's like an 80s icon
that I you know but he's done so much
you know he's directing he's writing
books he's he's just doing it and I love
that people are following their passion
and uh it doesn't matter what you've
done it's a matter of like what you're
doing for yourself
you know what I mean you could be a big
star and all that stuff but that if
that's all you got if you don't have
something on the side the passion Ryan
you have something on the side
a passion on the side
of this yeah no this is a Passion of the
Christ this is it no do you have it you
play guitar I play guitar I'm in several
Sports
dodgeball kickball soccer
oh you're doing it softball
yeah those are passions those are fun
yeah they are fun yeah yeah I enjoy them
it's nice to get out keep doing them uh
big shout out to the top tier patrons
thanks for listening thanks to Andrew
McCarthy for coming on the podcast
brother and uh these are the top tier
patrons patreon.com inside you these are
the guys that give a lot and I shout out
their names every episode and they get
packages and YouTube lives and many more
awesome things perks inside of you uh
patreon.comsite here we go shout outs uh
Nancy D Leah oh no
I I Leah yes and Leah K this time what
Leah K what are you gay it's not it's
got to be Leah s because she I think she
messaged me about that oh yeah Leah
stops unless she got married we need you
no she's already married all right two
kids again little Lisa remember her
she's awesome you Kiko yukiko's still
with us
Jill
Jill e correct Brian H Nico Robert
B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike
I'll dance
Chad D no bully you what what's this
that's a deeply you the w w is correct
Leanne
T can't forget Liam P Maya p
Maddie s correct Belinda n Dave
h e no you're right okay
uh Michael it's Dave I love Dave it's
only Dave isn't it Dave's really good
guys got a very subtle way of speaking
and I like him a lot so Sheila
uh G Brad d Ray h
t Tabitha T Tom and Talia M Betsy
D I miss Betsy oh say that angel M
Rhiannon C Corey l no d f Corey it
sounds like Corey Corey c okay okay
Court k Dev Nexon Michelle P just think
Canadian Michelle
hey hey it's correct Jeremy Irons
C Jeremy C Bogan
Brandy stretch
brandy brandy D correct Joey
see m m Eugene and Leah Corey Heather
page Heather remember I always say this
actress Heather L correct Jake
actor from State Farm Jake his father
was Gary B
Angela
BF Mel c s Caroline
Mel C was one of the Spice Girls
Caroline
Caroline um r r and then just remember
after R comes out so Christine asked
Caroline R Christine asks Eric
H Shane R Andrew M Tim L Oracle Amanda R
Jan B Kevin e Stephanie K Jarrell jam
and Jay Lee and Jay Luna R Mike F Stone
H Brian L Aaron R Kendall L Meredith I
Kara C Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Andrew
M Estevan G Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F
Marion Louise L Romeo the band Veronica
Q Frank B gen T and Nikki L couldn't do
this without you guys thank you so much
for the support and love I just messaged
back Everybody by the way who just
joined Patron I do it uh hopefully every
month and I message you guys so there
you go that's it
um thanks for listening another great
episode next week if you thought this
was great I did
um from the Hollywood Hills in
California I am Michael Rosenbaum I'm
Ryan Taylor's from Hollywood California
give a wave we love you guys thank you
be good to yourself I'll see you next
week
[Music]